hey guys I'm Lisa from the score eSports
this weekend we saw SKT face off against
kt rolster in the latest chapter of the
telecom war every time these two giants
meet were always gifted with Epic Games
and crazy plays so we've decided to take
a look back and count down the top 10
best plays from the telecom more kicking
off our list is not exactly a single
play but multiple plays from figures
Dianna in the 2015 lck champions at
SummerSlam arrow easy kill there see now
in a while
Oh Baker just buys arrow again Korean
players like that kind of utility it
does open up a lot of team compositions
that you could use on arrow again arrow
popke thunder heal but i don't think
it's getting out no baker just dive the
turret and take them down and they do do
is that the place so well off the
homeboy they caught again Baker is just
controlling of Jeff Baker big finger
does man I mean it it's happening
thank you someday Julie get the jungle
laptop co-captain arrow coming in though
there sir fellows Baker comes back in
bang whoa at banker flying arrow bang
you will live there going in arrow take
up a bakery you all right outside the
fountain coming in at number nine is an
amazing decoy play by bangin wolf during
the final game of the 2015 l ck summer
play-off final out that well as the
super minions push down the Nexus turret
some day just please get into that fight
he was trying to defend the base and he
had teleport off but SKT knew going on a
mission oh really map yeah yes we'll try
to distract autofill for aromantic your
house we're gonna hit this SRO
but man comes in takes one inhibitor in
he's doing for the next one they're
delaying it and bang is going to win
champion summer for his penis take hella
God three oh and the spring season three
Oh in the summer season this is a year
of escapee number eight on our list is
kt rolster score getting on across the
maps nice on Ezreal in Game one of the
2013 Oh G n hotfix summer finally I
think Malcolm state should be able to
get in Cataclysm trying to chase trying
to keep impact against the turrets but
it didn't work long enough everybody
gets out they get the kill but there
they make oh my god trueshot barrage
from score oh my god trueshot barrage in
the same series the seventh play on our
list is impact making a great escape
plan assassinate impact in response
because he's the target because he has
stand united auto dead instead for this
end in fact [ __ ] away comes back in that
was the wrong move he's got fun fire
cases on up trying to open away can he
do it
he cuts out ignite ticking down but with
the sealed coming in at number 6 on our
list is Katie's arrow somehow managing
to get around wolf to get the snipe on
edge Katie's bang in Game three of the
2016 lck my summer playoff cosmic
blinding devour comes through from wolf
with the curveball opens up and look at
her bags for wrapping around the
backside should be get either way Bart
ultimate will catch up or just lay my
bed to pull it around a wolf comes up
with the kill and our wolf that is one
is dead
[Music]
number five on our list is speaker doing
speaker things on Orianna delivering a
shockwaves that led to Katie beam eighth
in Game two in week six of the 2017 lck
spring clip ariana is never group with a
front line in front of her the poster
ball to cancel out the death mod maker
has been out of position because all
right how to have position and we hear
an ultimate popping week via turn yeah
that's right I'm coming through shock
like just so frakkin leaders absolutely
devastate to rake the kt rolster a
triple killer hip quad trying to get out
with his life but it just doesn't look
very likely it could God hook the
backside of the Baroness cake deep blow
the game from wide open Tony he led the
dreadlord pawn that door right we'll go
down Saturday for SK Telecom t1 that
right there is the 4000 elo shockwave
that is why faker is the ultimate game
breaker oh it looks so sweet for KT they
thought they could get the turn and then
it all lines up for faker look at this
one Bo Peep and farms up he hadn't got
to the five but that was the third of
all turns for SK Telecom taking number
four on our list is Katie's insects
showing why this play only sin was named
after him in the 2013 to 2014 l ck
winter playoff semi finals game over for
55% from SK Peter pinky another dragon
triple yeah that's right it takes
teleporting in but yet a third dragon
brisket got up he wasn't coming home
what a play pigley take it out of that
one title if not helping it Vaughn do it
binky on the run that was a beautiful
chain
[Music]
that was a beautiful thing Oh coming in
at number three is fakers insane
reaction time to dodge magnates
cassiopeia alt in the finals of the 2015
l ck summer spliffs lay off maybe a
little bit nervous about rappelling
under pterence wolf coming in double six
they get the classroom not a faker comes
in he's got yellow piece delta kill
beautiful bit of a nervous kt dodge that
petrifying pain so beautifully I almost
couldn't see it number two on our list
is SKT defending their base and turn you
the game around on Katy in the final
game of the series in week six of the
2017 lck spring split on you still
desperately holding on blank is up in
ten seconds Kent they buy enough time
for asset of ours but now everything's
going down figures it's going back in
trying to get up a score he pops the GA
but can he do enough it look like know
will not be able to yep firing away from
ticket scores here can you finish it off
the answer is going to be those resonate
going superb SK Telecom it looks so good
for Katy but they just cannot finish it
off and that to be in Katy winning the
game but surely this is it surely SKT
you've done it this game is seesaw so
many times but they're going to run it
Maud is dead and I think SKT have won a
Titanic series and just a most dramatic
fashion possible super Krete there to
back them up the tank off the turret
shot they take out both of them the
nesting spot er if there is anything you
could do
I'd be so damn impressed but it's just
hopeless now for Katy roles or SK
Telecom in such a passion for third game
are able to come out on top they win the
first telecom war on spring 2017 taking
first place on our list is none other
than the iconic duel the seed Baker
versus Ryu from Game five of the 2013 OG
n hot stick summer fights with the fed
opaque or maybe a trouble your death
mark tries to clean it up for you oh
look at the cleanse look at the bows
thank you what was that
[Music]
thank you would like you I lave
acuteness I can't so many but I just saw
you actually what that jewel I can't
believe after look on and there you have
it those were our picks for the top 10
best plays from the telecom war you
think something else should have made it
on the list
let us know in the comments below thanks
for watching if you want more great
content be sure to hit that subscribe
button
[Music]